hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
Facebook has a secret project called
Libra the company acquired the Libra
trade market back in June of 2018
however only recently have details about
the secretive projects come out what it
is is Facebook's own cryptocurrency
Facebook is reportedly building a
cryptocurrency based payment system the
social media giant is recruiting
financial firms and e-commerce companies
to help launch the payment platform
users would be able to send a digital
coin to each other and use that currency
to make purchases on Facebook and online
Facebook's plans may also include ways
to financially reward users who watch
with ads reports have even surfaced that
the company has recruited the help of
MIT crypto professor Christian Catalina
so what is Facebook up to in the secret
project let's take a look
you are walking and confusion TV
cryptocurrencies have seen a very public
boom-and-bust but that doesn't mean
they're going away the underlying
technology behind them is solid
facebook's interest in developing a
crypto coin of their own is shrouded in
mystery
what will the coin be used for and how
will it impact our daily lives according
to The Wall Street Journal Facebook is
currently looking for partners to invest
over a billion dollars into a fund which
will provide the financial backing for
Facebook's table coin this is an attempt
to dampen the erratic nature of most
cryptocurrencies as dictated by surges
in supply and demand the plan seems to
be a currency that Facebook uses within
its own marketplace in order to get
merchants on board Facebook appears to
be willing to offer lower fees than
credit cards
this means that Facebook will be
sacrificing their short-term return in
order to get people spending more time
on the platform and that's really the
aim of the game for facebook at the
moment they don't want your money they
want your time because that's worth a
lot more at Facebook's recent f8
developer conference Zuckerberg & Co
made some announcements in particular
about how commerce should interact with
the platform what's that a product of
Facebook will soon allow users to send
and receive money this is after some
promising tests in India other
executives also touted improved checkout
and Instagram shopping feature and
donation stickers allowing nonprofits to
receive money from donors Facebook's
marketplace is probably where most of
the action of the new Libre projects
will occur it makes perfect sense why
Facebook will try and incorporate their
own digital currency in order to make
the interaction between currency and
their services more streamlined but
should we be excited I don't think so at
the same conference Zuckerberg presented
the future of Facebook as a privacy
focused social platform something he
immediately admitted was not one of
Facebook's strong points due to the
recent scandals involving the company if
your memory is rusty this includes the
Cambridge analytical scandal as well as
other numerous projects that Facebook
helped governmental organisations with
one particular program was the NSA's
prism program which was publicly
revealed by Edward Snowden and caused
Snowden to flee the u.s. now sure other
companies such as Google Microsoft and
YouTube also
participated in the program but this is
simply highlighting that while Facebook
may say that they want to ensure privacy
historically this has not been the case
even though Zuckerberg is admitting this
this still bears the obvious question
why should we trust Facebook with our
money and our transactions is the
company liable to release our spending
habits or personal transactions two
governing bodies or firms like Cambridge
analytic are the main contention is
simply that Facebook's coin will make it
easier for governments to access this
information if spaced books coin becomes
a major form of payment it may force
people to abide by Facebook's guidelines
simply to buy and sell things this is
unlikely but it's not a good sign that
this is even a possibility a much more
likely scenario is simply that
Facebook's coin will be a parallel
payment method to the fiat currencies we
all use today because of this businesses
are unlikely to make their payment
method exclusively this type of currency
but inside Facebook's online marketplace
it's up to Facebook to make the rules
and in this market if you don't agree
with Facebook's values you may be
excluded from it all together this kind
of thing reminds me of an actual
technocracy where tech companies begin
to govern society although they already
do in a way adding a payment system into
the mix makes things a little more
serious the simple solution is just not
to use Facebook's currency on Facebook
Instagram or any of their other
platforms and that's the big question
will people use it maybe not in Western
markets but I could definitely imagine
such a system being huge in developing
markets it's a pivotal time for Facebook
with growing public distrust will the
company be able to convince people to
use their currency and more importantly
how will the coin be used and on another
note or if another company like Amazon
released their own currency what would
you say to that let me know your
thoughts in the comment section I think
it's an interesting discussion but
personally I'm not really a fan of it if
you like me and not really a fan of this
idea there might be a silver lining
perhaps if the Facebook coin works out
is going to further legitimize crypto
currencies for more organic and private
uses that's what we can hope for anyway
if that wraps it up for this video
thanks for watching if you enjoyed it
don't forget to subscribe this is
to gogo and you've been watching cold
fusion and I'll see you again soon for
the next video
cheers guys have a good one
I'm thinking
[Music]